- gross - creepy - sad or just too bad
sometimes a film dishes out more than we
can handle
whether it's crazy camera work or
unbearable scenes there are plenty of
reasons that audiences prematurely head
to the exits here are a few films that
were just too hard to sit through the
walk even seasoned film critics and
industry insiders felt the dizzying
effects of french daredevil Philippe
Petit walking a tightrope between
Manhattan's Twin Towers in 2015's the
walk the 3d biopic recreates the
notorious 1974 stunt in ways that pass
mediums including a memoir and a
documentary could not and that included
making people leave the theatre to vomit
CBS News even advised people to avoid
large meals before attending a screening
reporting that at least 10% of audiences
were getting physically ill all previous
footage of Patti's heart-stopping stroll
between the skyscrapers which he
completed eight times over 45 minutes
without a safety net or harness was
captured from the ground or the
buildings the thing that neither the
book nor the documentary could do was
actually put the audience up on the wire
with Philippe director Robert Zemeckis
told Vanity Fair we did and that is what
movies are all about that ends
apparently barfing freaks
director Todd Browning's pre-code horror
film about a 1932 circus proved so
shocking that the original copies were
pulled from theaters and destroyed along
with Browning's career in the movie a
gorgeous trapeze artist plans to marry
and then murder the leader of a group of
sideshow performers to gain his
inheritance
the plot fits the normal members of the
circus against the freaks browning made
the bold choice of casting real circus
folk with abnormalities to play the
sideshow performers viewers were
supposed to come away with the message
that one's looks do not equate to one's
morality but things didn't go as planned
it is impossible for the normal man or
woman to sympathize with the aspiring
[ __ ] said a contemporary review and
variety The Hollywood Reporter called it
an outrageous onslaught upon the
feelings the senses the brains and the
stomachs of an audience mass walkouts
ensued the film was banned in the UK and
according to the book horror movie freak
one woman threatened to sue MGM claiming
the movie made her miscarry
comparatively it's hard to comprehend
that level of loathing among today's
audiences American Horror Story
freakshow took home five Emmys in 2015
what a difference a day makes 127 hours
in 2003 outdoorsman Aron Ralston became
trapped in a slot canyon in Utah for 127
hours his right arm pinned by a boulder
to escape he sawed off his own arm with
a dull pocketknife in 2010 director
Danny Boyle released a movie starring
James Franco about the true story but
when viewers arrived at that pivotal
scene many couldn't hack it movie line
compiled reports of fainting vomiting
and seizures at film festivals and
screenings across the country Franco
told vulture it's meant to be an intense
personal immersive experience and when
he cuts off his arm maybe it feels like
it's happening to you despite the
suffering of movie goers the film was
nominated for six Academy Awards
including Best Picture and Best Actor so
let's give the film a hand it really
needs one
irreversible don't be ashamed at this
controversial 2002 French film makes you
want to curl up in the fetal position
critic Roger Ebert gave the movie three
stars but also called it so violent and
cruel that most people will find it
unwatchable he was right but it wasn't
just the brutality that overwhelmed
audiences there was also a scientific
explanation for their abhorrence
director Gaspar Inouye added
low-frequency background noise to the
soundtrack of his revenge thriller
though such extreme bass waves are
inaudible to humans the BBC reported
that infrasound can induce anxiety
extreme sorrow heart palpitations and
shivering naturally occurring infrasound
has been associated with areas of
supernatural activity as well as being
produced prior to natural disasters such
as storms and earthquakes our response
to certain kinds of noise is something
so profound in us that we can't switch
it off science writer Philip ball told
the BBC film composers know that and use
it to shortcut the logical part of our
brain and get straight to the emotional
centers the Paranormal Activity
franchise and other horror movies have
allegedly used this tactic as well so
the next time you're watching a movie
between your fingers don't fault your
courage blame the fear frequency tree of
life while film scholars call tree of
life a masterpiece the man on the street
asked for his money back Terrence
Malick's experimental drama explores
many themes the creation of the worlds
the meaning of life the conflict between
science and religion and the bonds
between family which is a lot for any
will be to handle tree of life dropped
the ball maybe it was just too much for
the average date night because folks
left the movie in droves they work
scared or grossed out they just didn't
like it despite an 85 percent Metacritic
rating disputes about refunds arose and
theaters scrambled to make their
policies clear according to the New York
Times the Avon theatre in
get posted a sign urging customers to
read up on the film before choosing to
see it because it was not issuing
refunds other cinemas agreed to
reimbursements for those who left within
30 minutes and Brad Pitt laughed all the
way to the bank Cloverfield
if this 2008 found-footage horror film
makes you lose your lunge
fear not you're not alone so many people
got sick during screenings that some
cinemas began posting warning signs in
the movie 6 Manhattan Millennials are
attending a party when a gigantic
monster attacks the city their
experience is documented on a personal
video camera later recovered by the US
Department of Defense the footage is so
jerky that bucket bowls of popcorn were
regurgitating in cinema seats bathrooms
and the expansive floor between us even
the batteries because instances of
nausea were so prevalent Web MD even
wrote an article about the specific
motion sickness phenomenon stating while
watching Cloverfield viewers were
sitting still in their seats so their
inner ear was telling their body they
were motionless but the bumpy camera
movements and their eyes mislead them
into thinking they were moving
erratically similar side effects occur
during screenings of The Blair Witch
Project in 1998
fortunately Cloverfield first quasi spin
off the 2016 hit 10 Cloverfield Lane
dispensed with the jiggli camerawork
opting for good old-fashioned jiggly
John Goodman instead thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment